I'm the first um Saudi bikini model sir
you know what oh don't disrespect her
okay fine all right
leaving she's emotional um Miss uh Haram
so get out all right
I've come together with the one on my
charity which is 100 donation policy and
do amazing work around the world this
winter brother sisters helped to feed
those who are in poor conditions and who
don't even have a clothing to keep
theirself warm your small donation might
mean nothing to you but it can change
their life and help them survive the
winter this year
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends as you guys might know I have a
lot of discussion with feminists the
opposite gender and they always talk
about freedom and Liberation and the
sexual Liberation and they can do
whatever they like with their body and
this has also gone all the way to our
sisters in the Muslim countries and it's
affected and indoctrinated them so much
that they think freedom is going and
doing whatever you like thinking they
are free thinking they're making a
choice now this video that we're gonna
watch is heartbreaking and at the same
time a eye-opener for us let's get
straight into hi my name is okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay so far it just seems I don't know
if you guys can see this but she seems
like she's out of place she seems like
it's as if I can as if I don't know you
guys saw me as if she doesn't belong
there like even from a demeanor the way
she is she doesn't look comfortable she
looks like she's out of this is as if
she wants to fit in well she's not one
year ago but I was in the state three
years ago okay all right then uh single
married single single okay
um and then happily thinking
okay happily single what does that mean
happily single let's be honest nobody
likes to be single nobody wants to spend
the rest of their life alone so this is
one of the biggest delusions you know
why women fall into this because they
meet men who use and abuse them get one
thing out of them they hate all men and
they Rebel and I'm happily single no
you're not you went about things the
wrong way and this not just doesn't go
over there with every single woman and
now you're hurt and you don't trust any
man any man you've just become broken
into pieces
and then uh
uh
I'm doing my masters right now okay what
are you uh what are you majoring in
there um Hospitality um specialized and
make events okay and then let's see here
do you work right now or is a full-time
student I used to work at the Red Cross
in South Beach but I quit and now I'm
doing only fans
okay I'm the first um Saudi bikini model
sir
yes the only Saudi bikini model you go
girl boss babe you go get you some and
there's all these girls around them who
are dressed up disgustingly because
that's the only thing they have to offer
and they are there that whoa the first
Saudi bikini go oh what is a bikini
what's a bikini bikinis underwear it's
just given another name it's like for
example a strip club they call it
Gentleman's Club giving it another name
doesn't take away from the fact of how
disgusted it is so you walking around
with anybody by the way anyone can work
how they want bikini is exactly the same
thing as a woman wearing underwear there
is no such there's no difference it's
just called the bikini oh I'm in a
bikini no you are in a underwear you're
walking around in your underwear and
only that what did you do only fans whoa
go get you some girl do whatever you
like on there you know let men just use
you abuse you like a piece of meat which
studies show that when men see women in
bikini the part of the brain that lights
off for two years meaning you're like a
screwdriver to them you're like
something that's an inanimate object
you're not even human being in their
eyes but it's okay sister you left out
for the freedom of the West whoa let's
carry on but I am power woman oh [ __ ]
okay fantastic one more time again relax
I go with Princess cookie because my
family does not agree on whatever I'm
doing with my real names
I can only imagine yeah
do you think it's a power only offense
is it empowering for you in Saudi Arabia
it's very empowering
the creation will never be happy with
you Allah will never be happy with you
the angels will be never happy with you
and this is what we've seen look how
uncomfortable yeah I'm proud I'm proud
of myself I'm empowering what is
empowering about you dressed in an
appropriate way in modest way and there
are men masturbating over you around the
world envisioning you in God knows what
and masturbating of you your family
wants the best for you your family cares
about you that they don't want you to
fall for this pit of disgusting scum
lifestyle and you are here doing that
look at how these guys ended up treating
her watch this guys well Allah is the
lesson to be learned watch this exactly
exactly because I'm just breaking all
these Cycles from forbidden stuff and I
girls shouldn't do this and girls
shouldn't do that and I think every girl
has the freedom to do whatever she wants
and I don't think any guy has the right
okay so um let me ask you this I'll go
on a table do you think it's empowering
show your body to her by the way there's
Haram and Halal for men and women not
one Islam doesn't say a woman cannot
have sex before marriage but a man can
no they both have the capital punishment
the both of them have a punishment in
this life and in the Hereafter unless
they repent so this notion as if just
women can't do something we're only
Islam does it say that a man my son the
father son can go and mess around with
girls no he will get back hand he will
get the backhand best believe that not
oh you're my son you no no no no both of
them I would not allow my daughter or
son to go down that route why because I
care about them you think it is
empowering that going on these platforms
yes and the only thing that you can
offer is your body parts and you think
that's empowering you're empowering
other girls to come do you really think
you're free look what she said she goes
that I believe every woman should be
free no man should tell her what to do
really so let me get this right so men
for example you think that woman who
cover theirselves up cover it for men no
they do it for Allah my dear sister if
you're listening to this yeah however
Men actually want you to to be naked
because that's why that's what they want
to see do you think a man wants to see a
woman covering up no he doesn't he wants
to see it as naked as possible so he can
just look at her and drool over her and
do God knows what masturbating God knows
what other stuff imagination in his
brain yes literally rape you with his
mind with his eyes yes so you think
about his freedom do you really think
that you are freely doing this no you're
not you are affected by the Western
World they have given you dawah to their
lifestyle yes to tell you that this is
okay do what you like you go girl do you
really think you have a choice no you
don't everything has an impact on you
the movies that you watch to the
Billboards that you see to your uh
colleagues under the society that you
live in the society the peer pressure
the beauty industry read the book called
Beauty sick I recommend every system
reader read it and see the lengths women
are going down to to look to have this
ident ideal body and some of them would
even go down the route of giving sex
away just so the men don't leave them
and you think this is empowered by me so
um let me ask you this I'll go on a
table do you think it's empowering to
show your body off to strangers whacking
off to you
because that's honestly what's going on
that's why the people are watching you
that is what is actually going on behind
the screen they're whacking off you
being naked is that a power if there are
women who have been disrespected their
entire life and told that their
sexuality is something that they should
be ashamed of but they find the freedom
to project all of that to the world and
they're able to release that to the
world and and disarm themselves of the
shame of their natural sexuality and
their bodies and be completely proud of
just who they are amen absolutely sorry
yeah when has sexuality become something
that they should be frowned upon where
in Islam does it says that you as a
woman are frowned upon no it doesn't
Islam is there to protect you to protect
you as a woman to Savages who are after
you to break you down give you no rights
and take what they want and go Islam
says no Islam is there to protect you by
telling you that woman men should not
sexually objectify you and women talk
about ah I don't want to be sexually
objectified but all of these girls there
are sitting with their breasts are open
mini skirts all they talk about is this
and that how many guys they say Etc you
sexualize your own self and you don't do
sexual objectified Islam says cover
yourself and he also tells the man to
lower your keys Islam doesn't say if a
girl's dressed up in bikini you can look
at her no we are told that we need to
lower our gaze regardless of what she's
wearing that teaches men how to view
women and then on top of that the woman
has to do a path by covering up also and
if I want to get married to a woman I go
and speak to her father I have to give a
dowry which is her right I have to give
her a wedding I have to marry her not
use an abuser with these girls around
the table they probably have 30 40
bodies yes the people that step with
empowering whoa that men are using you
like toilets how when I want to relieve
myself I go to the toilet these men
because they are horny and their sexual
urges are whatever they are releasing
themselves in you excuse me excuse me
kids are watching this they are doing
exactly that you are nothing but a
toilet to them that's when they have the
urge let me go to this toilet and
release myself oh I'm good now now get
lost because that's the only thing you
have to offer me because I'm not even
going to marry you whoa so empowering
though we're empowered yes let's go boss
baby so you're saying that's fine and
that's fine but at the end of the day
yes I do believe that it can be
extremely empowering and it just depends
on who you are and where you're coming
from and what you've been through and
what you've had to go through to get to
the point where you say you know what
this is me and I accept it and I love it
and I'm comfortable with it and I'm
proud so Timmy goes to school yes she's
the only fans page that might be yours
okay right he's 15 years old okay get
someone from school yes it takes the
pounds off okay walks off
I find it very interesting how women
don't want consequences for poor
decisions if you sexualize yourself as a
woman nine out of ten times every man
you deal with is going to sexualize you
as well it's reciprocation a man cannot
objectify you unless you objectify
yourself first correct that's the
reality so correct you're saying Society
you know does these things and
constructs women sexuality whatever what
if it's to protect them and the reason
why is to protect them is to keep men
from giving them the evil eye and
objectifying them and looking them at
nothing more than a sexual object what
if it's a promo modesty what if it's a
keep that woman's value High to a degree
where people don't disrespect her okay
fine all right sorry leaving she's
emotional um Miss uh Haram so get our
help all right make a quick then we're
gonna make it a whole uh you know okay
thing just let her get her stuff and
yeah
and take our Instagram off the thing too
yeah Shorty's crying and here's the
thing that's actual apartment for you
when you can't speak about what you do
openly and you you feel certain way it
goes back to the biology now women know
deep down that yo this is not acceptable
information I'm gonna wrap up on this
guys what can I say what can I say
wellahi people who are turning their
back on their lord Allah Islam the most
beautiful thing that's ever been gifted
to me
brothers and sisters you're turning it
back and you went Wonder from these
people well humiliated
she came back I think it's going to be
empowered like whoa you go girl wallahi
my dear sister if you're watching this
Allah put you through that to turn back
to him
if that is not a sign that these people
will never be happy with you nobody's
ever going to be happy with you the men
are going to use you like you're a piece
of tissue that they wipe their nose and
throw you away
Islam isista every woman that's watching
this
well lie Islam has come to preserve and
honor you to increase your status in
this life and in the Hereafter this
decided that girl who's talking there
empowerment all this kind of nonsense
yet who's probably been slept used by
multiple men multiple men chucked away
broken and she's there telling oh this
is my empowerment it's parman you choose
to why on Earth would you come on a show
with your breasts hanging out why why do
you have to make your breasts and go
I'm curious why why mini skirts why why
can you not have more to offer your
sexual objective for yourself and then
you say but why do my sexual objectify
me
what do you want to do if you're dressed
up in a certain way of course certain
men are gonna treat you as a certain way
we wish that didn't happen I wish that
never happened but that's the reality of
the world we live in and that's why God
Almighty has told men and women how to
conduct themselves with their eyes to
their tongue to the way they dress and
you are talking about empowerment and
you think you choose to dress up like
this that no societal pressures have an
impact on you of course they do the fact
that all of those girls most of them
there who are dressed inappropriately
shows you one thing you are all
following a specific Trend and you're
there I choose to no you don't no you
don't why don't you come to the show
fully covered why not because this is
Titan Norms or what mini skirt
breast hanging out you know lips are
this big like a balloon
and they're telling me you're free well
why if that is freedom
it's the biggest enslavement
if you're watching this wallahi turn to
Allah it's not late turn back to your
family leave this filthy lifestyle while
he leaves this lifestyle maybe you
learned your lesson Allah put you
through that well just learn your lesson
inshallah and turn back to your lord and
what else can I say of Allah is sad so
sad to see females not just Muslim
non-muslim that they are going down this
route if they understood and a glimpse
of what Islam has to offer them Allah
they will leave it in a
but let's still leave that lifestyle how
Islam honors them hope you guys
benefited from this problem sisters and
may Allah keep us firm and protect our
daughters our sisters our mothers